né il ya une quarantaine d'années le
label petite cité de caractère s'affiche
aujourd'hui dans 135 communes françaises
des communes rurales qui partagent le
même objectif la sauvegarde du
patrimoine comme levier de développement
des territoires
six communes du cher pourrait bientôt
rejoindre ce réseau
4 contacté leur candidature mais assure
y est vrai sans serre doivent encore la
confirmer on s'est rendu compte qu'on
avait un patrimoine exceptionnel à
l'échelon du cher et plus largement du
berry et que finalement ce patrimoine
était assez peu valorisé donc c'est pour
ça qu'une marque quand une petite cité
de caractère pour nous ça va être
l'assurance d'avoir des retombées
économiques fortes et puis une notoriété
en pleurs renforcer plus de visibilité
plus d'attractivité
mais aussi la promesse de fixer les
touristes sur le département en leur
offrant un véritable parcours de
découverte des richesses patrimoniales
du cher comme l'environnement médiévale
de sagone la tradition porcelainière de
mehun sur yèvre où l'identité viticole
du sancerrois en dehors effectivement de
l'attractivité viticole en lien avec les
vins sincères qui sont connus à travers
le monde il ya aussi la valorisation du
patrimoine bâti et d'un savoir-faire en
fait séculaire en lien avec le vignoble
qui repose donc sur nombreuses
générations et qui pourra être
potentiellement valoriser à travers à
travers cette labellisation de petites
cités de caractère
pour l'heure les communes candidates
n'en sont qu'au début de la procédure
entre le dépôt de candidature et
l'attribution du label il faut compter
en moyenne trois à cinq ans